sechs von der kernschmelze der
finanzsysteme war die rede in jedem
herbst 2008 das klang nach weltuntergang
als zunächst die us-amerikanische
investmentbank lehman brothers ins glas
bis und eine reihe anderer
finanzinstitute ins straucheln kam
sowas darf nie wieder passieren schworen
sich damals alle beteiligten zehn jahre
lehman-pleite wo stehen wir heute zu
unserer sendetitel
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns live zuschauer
meine gäste im studio andrea rexer ist
bei uns leiten der redakteurin finanzen
bei der süddeutschen zeitung
peer steinbrück vor zehn jahren zu
zeiten der finanzkrise
bundesfinanzminister
das war dem ausscheiden aus der politik
ist er unter anderem berater des
vorstandes einer bank professor hans
werner sinn ist bei uns von 1999 bis
2016 präsident des ifo instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung und marc friedrich
sie beschäftigen sich intensiv in der
globalen wirtschaft und den
finanzmärkten sind co autor einer reihe
von bestsellern ihr aktuelles buch trägt
den titel sonst knallts warum die
wirtschaft und politik radikal neu
denken müssen
liebe zuschauer es war das bild die
szene die wahrscheinlich in deutschland
am stärksten in erinnerung bleibt von
der finanzkrise 2008 und folgende es war
der auftritt im kanzleramt von zwei uns
wohlbekannten politikern am 5 oktober
2008 wir sagen den sparerinnen und
sparern dass ihre einlagen sicher sind
auch dafür steht die bundesregierung ein
ja ich möchte dir nur unterstreichen
dass in der tat in der gemeinsamen
verantwortung die wir in der
bundesregierung fühlen wir dafür sorge
tragen wollen dass die sparer nun sparer
in deutschland nicht befürchten müssen
einen euro ihre einlagen zu verlieren
herr steinbrück haben sie in dem moment
wirklich an das geglaubt hast du da vor
den kameras gesagt haben hatten sie da
dabei ein gutes gewissen
ich hielt es für notwendig und ich habe
daran geglaubt und ich bin bis auf den
heutigen tag ziemlich sicher dass eine
solche garantie erklärung der
bundesregierung im zweifelsfall hätte
erfüllt werden müssen
andererseits wäre das vertrauen in
demokratische institutionen noch tief
erschüttert worden als ohnehin schon
durch die bankenkrise und folgende
ereignisse
das sind sie haben später die kosten der
euro-rettung die ja aus diesen crash
entstanden sind heftig kritisiert aber
hat die bundesregierung vielleicht
damals sogar zu wenig geld in die hand
genommen um die banken zu stabilisieren
über sie hat ja kein also zunächst
einmal jedenfalls kein geld in die hand
genommen sondern eine garantie
ausgesprochen und das war in der
situation absolut richtig aber im
fortgang alles zum hohlen jahren nachher
2010 gingen dann die landesbanken pleite
oder kamen schwierigkeiten die
commerzbank und da hat man in der summe
280 milliarden euro für eine bad bank
auf den tisch legen müssen
das ist nicht alles verloren das geld
aber es ist zumindest schon mal eine
zusätzliche staatsverschuldung gewesen
8 prozent des bips würde ich sie sind ja
auch einer der kritiker der euro rettung
gab es denn 2008 wirklich eine
alternative zu dem was dann von der
deutschen und auch der europäischen
politik beschlossen wurde eigentlich
nicht natürlich war diese garantie diese
abgegeben haben nicht realisierbar im
worst case szenario aber es war darum
die menschen zu beruhigen weil es schon
einen bank run gab und den wollte man
auf jeden fall verhindern
die nachfolgenden entscheidung waren
definitiv falsch es gab keine bank waren
bis dahin in deutschland es gab eine in
großbritannien northern rock lange
schlangen aber nicht in deutschland ein
deutschland gab es auch vereinzelt bank
runs bei verschiedenen sparkassen
unabhängig davon wissen sie genau so gut
wie ich das natürlich im extremfall
diese garantie nicht gezählt hätte man
statt der über zwei millionen schulden
hat kann nicht für das vermögen seiner
kunden aber vielleicht weiß er
oktober gegen also die kassenbestände in
den bankautomaten so allmählich zu ende
und man kam kaum noch nach neues geld
nachzuschieben nicht es war das signal
weshalb wir dann vor die kameras
getreten sind aber ich bleibe dabei wir
haben über die spareinlagen geredet wir
haben nicht über andere
finanzmarktprodukte geredet und im
zweifelsfall hätte das land leidet die
bundesregierung und die bundesrepublik
deutschland garantieren müssen
ich könnte jetzt sollten vor allen
dingen die 200 und 500 euro scheine die
sowieso niemand ist eine
beruhigungspille nicht mehr in den
bankautomaten vorgefunden worten von
adexa war die erschütterung damals groß
genug um lerneffekte zu erzeugen in der
politik
bei den banken bei der bankenaufsicht in
der wirtschaft an der börse also auf
jeden fall der erschütterung war enorm
und man sieht an den in den
verschiedensten aspekten das gelernt
wurde hinzugelernt wurde vielleicht
nicht immer ausreichend aber allein in
den jahren 2008 bis 2013 haben die
europäischen grossbanken fast 200
milliarden zusätzliches kapital
aufgenommen man zieht das ist ein
deutlich größere risikopuffer auch bei
der aufsicht hat man sich
internationalisiert es gibt es eine
gemeinsame europäische aufsicht für die
großen banken
all das sind schritte nach vorne
vielleicht nicht genug an der einen oder
anderen stelle kann mir noch darüber
reden aber lerneffekte sich schon ganz
klar also sie ihn denn in den tagen und
wochen nach der lehman-pleite durch den
kopf gegangen aber das vielleicht auch
die angst dieses mal stand er wie ein
menetekel an der wand diese
weltwirtschaftskrise von 1929 können
dass ich irgendwie wiederholen mit all
den gefahren die damit verbunden sind
ich war damals korrespondenten in wien
und das war auch tatsächlich mein erstes
berufs jahr 2007 habe ich begonnen zu
arbeiten und in wien war das ganz
besonders interessant denn einerseits
weil man sehr weit weg von den usa aber
andererseits kennt man die geschichte
aus der 1929 wo die erste bank die ins
rollen kam oder die ins wanken kam die
bank austria creditanstalt war oder ich
damals kritiker und deswegen waren
sofort diese historischen szenen wieder
im kopf hier könnte ein großer
dominoeffekt kommen das fand ich damals
wirklich sehr spürbar im gespräch mit
den mit den experten dort vor ort ich
habe sie als verantwortlicher minister
hatten sie auch ein mulmiges gefühl in
diesen tagen ja wobei ich gerne zugebe
dass ich am anfang diesen über sprungs
effekte von einer immobilienkrise in den
usa auf die internationalen banken
märkte nicht so vorausgesehen habe es
gibt einige wenige denen ich hier die
ehre zuteil werden lassen dass sie es
gesehen habe insbesondere einen mann bei
der damaligen bank für internationalen
zahlungsverkehr biz mister right aber
das ist diese erschütterungsdynamik
gegeben hat das musste man dann erste
lernen aber ich glaube wir haben es dann
gelernt
nicht nur deutschland sondern auch
andere länder sind in der lage gewesen
handlungsfähig zu werben wir haben in
einer seltenen geschwindigkeit ein
finanzmarktstabilisierungsgesetz durch
die verfassungsorgane dieses landes
getragen andere länder auch g20 ist
gegründet worden
wir haben eine banken union inzwischen
noch nicht vollständig aber das was frau
weg sagte es richtig sehr viel stärkere
eigenkapitalanforderungen
liquiditätspuffer absatz trotzdem sich
risiken ja dann sich da mal rein geräte
hier ranken union ist der de facto
eigentlich jetzt schon das ganze jetzt
gehen wir noch was hatten wir hatten
sich dass damit darauf reagiert auf
diese im spätherbst also wir waren klar
an dem tag als lehman brothers pleite
ging
das was ganz großes passiert ist es war
eine zeitenwende ein epochaler wandel
weil lehman brothers war immerhin die
viertgrößte investmentbank der welt mit
einer bilanzsumme von 700 milliarden
dollar und dafür wurde aber erst ein
jahr zuvor gerettet neben dem blatt das
nicht es war ein deutliches signal aber
die lerneffekte daraus waren relativ
kurz war schon im jahr 2009 als die
börsen dann wird er nach oben gegangen
sind haben die politiker sich wieder dem
alltag hingegeben und all die
versprechen die uns gegeben worden wie
wir werden die banken an die kandare
nehmen finanztransaktionssteuer usw
wurden bis zum heutigen tage nicht
wirklich umgefüllt und die banken union
zb ist ja eigentlich schon gescheitert
wenn man nach italien aus diese dieses
weltweite katastrophenszenario ich habe
vorhin auch ein wort zitiert dass der
häufige benutzt wurde kernschmelze der
finanzmärkte hatten sie das befürchtet
im spätherbst 2008 ja es ist ja so weit
war auf jeden fall das hat dann ja jeder
gefürchtet ich meine die frage ist wer
hat wann was rechtzeitig befürchtet das
war ging er damals die man das damals
selbst erlebt hat
denn ja es war ja nicht als ich die
entscheidung getroffen wurde da musste
man das befürchten deswegen es war auch
die entscheidung richtig
die kernschmelze stand kurz bevor und es
musste irgendwie gehandelt werden es
muss zur sicherheit erzeugt werden das
problem ist nur dass der ausstieg nicht
gefunden wurde ein jahr später ging ja
die weltkonjunktur schon wieder hoch
genauso stark hoch wie sie vorher
untergegangen war und dann hätte man
eigentlich zu einem normalen regime
übergehen müssen auch mit der politik
der zentralbank der europäischen
zentralbank die ja auch dass die
geldmärkte damals geflutet hat und das
ist nicht passiert und man geht immer
leicht rein in diese schutzmaßnahmen
auch heraus ist der weg sehr sehr schwer
und dann treten gewöhnungseffekte auf
und dann gibt es probleme zweiter art ja
wie bei einem kranken sommer mal jemand
der ist hysterisch man gibt eben eine
droge das auch mal ruhig ist ne dann
gewöhnt dass sich aber an die droge und
kommt überhaupt nicht mehr los und das
ist heute die situation noch eine frage
zur damaligen zeit sein wird
das welche atmosphäre welche stimmung
herrschte da denn eigentlich in der
politik oder das gelassenheit durch
seine coolness krisen management oder
auch ziemlich viel hektik viel
verzweiflung und hilflosigkeit gelassen
hat bestimmt nicht denn es ist
hinzuzufügen des 24 stunden nach lehman
eine noch viel größere katastrophe
drohte nämlich die liquidität oder sogar
insolvenz von lg dem größten
versicherungskonzern der welt und der
vielen telefonaten auch mit den
amerikanern dann verhindert werden
konnte weil in dem falls sie sich anders
verhielten als im fall von lehman bei
lehman hatte man den eindruck dass die
amerikanische politik ins ferne
finanzminister damals hank paulson so
ein bisschen in das chinesische
sprichwort vor augen hatten wenn man die
affen waren wild schlachter ein huhn um
die anderen jungs der wall street zu
signalisieren wir sind nicht dazu da
eure risiko ignoranz und euro zockerei
in jedem fall staatlich abzusichern
aber es war die stressigste und
schlaflose zeit die sich vorstellen
können
eine unentwegt der abfolge von terminen
gesprächen finanzministerrat ezb und es
wurde zum ersten mal eine g20-gruppe
zusammengetrommelt um auch die
auswirkung außerhalb nordamerikas und
europas mit zu berücksichtigen
es gab ja damals schon eine
bankenaufsicht aber die hatte irgendwie
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere ihren
namen gar nicht verdienen die für die
erfasst ein schattendasein weil sie auch
gar keine befugnisse hatte über das
beobachten hinaus auch wirklich
einzugreifen war das auch einer der
gründe dass die banken möglicherweise
politik da auch zum teil ausgetrickst
haben im vorfeld dieser pleite was das
kernproblem war glaube ich dass der
finanzmarkt schon längst global war aber
die aufsicht immer noch national und
dass die nationalen aufseher auch nicht
geschafft über die grenzen hinweg zu
schauen und zu sehen welche verbindungen
gibt es inzwischen den instituten und
welche risiken drohen uns denn von
anderswo sozusagen importiert bei uns
rein zu brechen und deswegen finde ich
dass so eine grandiose leistung die in
diesem jahr vollbracht wurde von den
handelnden akteuren auf globaler ebene
sich zusammenzuraufen mit kühlen kopf zu
sagen wir arbeiten wir finden eine
lösung und diese dramatische krise die
uns gedroht hätte abzuwenden finde ich
schon das ist eine leistung die jetzt
immer so ein hintergrund tritt weil man
sagt ja es sind noch so viele probleme
da ja die sind da aber das damals
geschafft wurde global zusammen zu
arbeiten finde ich grandios und das
würde ja heute wahrscheinlich anders
aussehen die politik damals was
finanzmärkte angehen was banken an gegen
das bankensystem steinberg so eine art
tal der ahnungslosen
sie machen die politik insgesamt also
das heißt wie man mit denen mit den
themen umgegangen ist sondern
offensichtlich überrascht war dass auch
die reaktion irgendwie zunächst mal auch
selbst gesagt hilflos gewirkt haben hat
man sich da einfach zu sehr von den
banken was vormachen lassen
ich habe bankenvorstände erlebt die
selber keine ahnung hat welche produkte
eigentlich gehandelt werden und wie die
aussagen in ihrer komplexität und
zugegebenermaßen die politik auch nicht
in meinen augen ging ist aber eine
zentrale frage auch danach bei wem liegt
eigentlich der primat wer hat den
taktstock
und ist es eine demokratisch
legitimierte politik oder sind es völlig
entgrenzte global agierende unternehmen
die nach ihren eigenen spielregeln
spielen das ist das eine das zweite ist
gewesen dass eine illusion verflogen
nämlich dass in der marktwirtschaft eine
funktionierende marktwirtschaft haftung
und risiko zusammenfällt und plötzlich
stellten viele fest stimmt nicht
diejenigen die risiko ignorant waren
diejenigen die sich verzockt hatten
mussten letztlich in letzter konsequenz
nicht für ihr handeln haften sondern es
musste der steuerzahler und das hat eine
langzeitwirkung die bis heute anhält
es war aber kein moralisches thema
sondern ein regulatorisches hatte in den
jahren vorher ein der regulierungs
wettbewerb gegeben
jeder staat hat sich gesagt na ja also
wenn ich jetzt zu scharf bin dann geht
das bankgeschäft in das andere land
nicht bleibe ich mit ein bisschen mit
meinen anforderungen unter dem
nachbarland dann ziehe ich die banken an
und kritisierte die regulierung umso
besser je mehr deregulierung desto mehr
bankengeschäft kriegt man und es war
also ein wettbewerb nach unten race to
the bottom nennt man und das und es war
ja extrem es war so extrem dass die
großen banken mit weniger als zwei
prozent eigenkapital in der bilanz summe
arbeiten durften zum beispiel die
deutsche bank die ubs weniger als zwei
prozent das haben sie dann hochgerechnet
indem sie es nicht durch die bilanzsumme
geteilt haben sondern durch die summe
der risikogewichteten aktiven haben wir
fünf mal so große zahl raus das war eine
mogelpackung in wahrheit haben sie ein
geschäft von 100 gemacht haben für 100
ausgeliehen hatten zwei eigenes geld 98
geliehenes geld für den fall dass das
geschäft gut lief hätten sie die gewinne
ausgeschüttet an die eigentümer dieser
2% und für den fall dass es schlecht
lief ging man davon aus dass entweder
die fremdkapitalgeber die zeche zahlen
würden oder der steuerzahler nicht wenn
es nämlich so weit ist gehört es zum
geschäft der banken zu rufen hier ihr
könnt euch uns nicht untergehen lassen
wenn wir untergehen gehen wir alle
gemeinsam unter und dann werden die
politiker natürlich zu recht nervös und
machen ihr portemonnaie auflegen das auf
den tisch wenn auch nur als bürgschaft
und dann ist erstmal wieder ruhe da ist
ja auch dann gar keine alternative ich
hätte es auch nicht anders gemacht
aber das problem ist dass man den banken
durchgehen lässt
mit so wenig eigenkapital zu arbeiten
von ihren kunden verlangen sie 30
prozent eigenkapital
damals hatten sie zwei selber heute
haben sie vielleicht drei bis vier ist
auch noch nicht viel
also diese eigenkapitalregelungen reicht
die man noch nicht das wären bei weitem
nicht also beim will richtung acht oder
zehn gehen
basel aber dass in sachen abkommen wo
das genau ist noch entstanden während
der finanzkrise aber dass nur noch weit
davon entfernt und die banken können das
auch nicht erfüllen es wurde es auch
verschoben auf 2019
aber selbst das reicht nicht wenn sie
als privatperson zu bank wollen um
immobilienkredit zu bekommen dann
brauchen sie mindestens 20 bis 30
prozent eigenkapital aber diejenigen die
mit geld täglich handeln haben momentan
unter fünf prozent da läuft etwas
gewaltig schief und dann der krasse
fehlanreiz natürlich der systemrelevanz
die banken haben sich ja voll gesaugt
und billig und geld sind seitdem noch
wichtiger geworden noch systemrelevant
und können bei der nächsten krise davon
ausgehen dass sie wieder rufen hallt
stoppt wird ein system das ist ein big
to fail to fail gilt nach wie vor auf
jeden fall denn das war ja einer der
gründe warum man eigentlich zu dingen
gezwungen war die man eigentlich nicht
machen wollte damals bei der bei der
bewältigung der clubs hängt nicht nur
davon ab die banken hängen ja alle
untereinander zusammen also auch viele
kleine sind gleichzeitig im risiko muss
ich auch retten dann lasst ihr bei
lehman brothers waren ja auch nicht
einer der ganz großen gewesen ja ja so
gezeigt hat dass eigentlich die
krisenverursacher die krisengewinner
worden weil dies herr steinberg richtig
gesagt hat risiko und haftung gehören
eigentlich zusammen es gilt für alle
branchen und für jeden hier am tisch
aber halt nicht für die finanz branche
jetzt diesen krassen fehlanreiz zu
wissen wenn es hart auf hart kommt
können wir sagen stopp ist system
relevanter werden gerettet werden
bedenklich ist dass die banken ja auch
noch größer geworden sondern es wird
sich die großen und institute anschauen
die sind noch größer als vor der krise
und wir jetzt reden wir in deutschland
wieder darüber dass vielleicht die
deutsche bank die commerzbank zusammen
gehen könnten und wird dass wir dann
noch nie gigant thuban kendra zwischen
vertut geboten also so gut dieses akute
krisen management war so sehr haben sich
politiker glaube ich danach ein bisschen
einlullen lassen und dann ganz
komplizierte regelwerk namens basel 3
bis ins detail versucht hinein zu
regulieren aber dann das große wichtige
die richtig großen eigenkapitalpuffer
vernachlässigt gewissen
das ist ganz klar dass am letzten krisen
immer wieder bewiesen umso mehr sie
dereguliert werden umso größer werden
die krisen weil sie zu spekulationen
aber werden sie reguliert werden machen
sie ihr geschäft nicht mehr weil das
bankengeschäft im casino kapitalismus
resultiert genau aus dieser asymmetrie
wenn es gut läuft werden die gewinne
privatisiert und schlecht läuft zeigt
der steuerzahler und ab und zu läuft
sagen halt schlecht und im mittel macht
man auf diese weise gewinner durch
diesen trick kann man die 25 prozent
rendite auf das eigenkapital erzielen
von der von denen herr ackermann zum
beispiel damals geredet hat es ist ja
kein normales geschäftsgebaren haben bei
der krisenbewältigung und bei der
schadensbegrenzung schadensbeseitigung
haben wir unseren europäischen partnern
also in der eurozone vor allen dingen da
unsere sicht der dinge aufgezwungen
nach dem motto jeder kümmert sich um
seine probleme und wenn es nicht anders
geht dann müsst ihr eben beinhart sparen
ich kenne den fünf das damals angebliche
erwachsene von dem präsident sarkozy und
man damaligen kollegin madame lagarde
nicht aufgegriffen worden sind wir
müssen eine große europäische lösung
finden
ich kann mich nicht so genau daran
erinnern ein solches angebot aus
frankreich gehört zu haben die
abstimmung damals in europa war
jedenfalls nicht schlecht bezogen auf
den finanzministerrat in sogenannten ego
fiel die abstimmung mit jean claude
vigée als damaligen präsidenten der ezb
und auch bilateral zwischen den
finanzministern
das hat 2008/2009 eigentlich ganz gut
funktioniert hinterher ist einiges doch
in gang gekommen auch bei den
eigenkapitalanforderungen sind deutlich
weitere schritte vollzogen worden
vielleicht nicht ausreichend aber wenn
sie anders denken was jetzt basel 3.5
und der sora 4.0 genannt wird dann sind
diese eigenkapitalanforderungen sehr
viel stärker und es gibt sogar eine
debatte das inzwischen zunehmend auch
staatsanleihen mit eigenkapital
unterlegt werden müssen was eine enorme
auswirkungen hätte auch auf den
verschuldungsgrad von ländern übrigens
ein anderer risikofaktor den ich sehe ja
das deutsche paradigma ist ziemlich klar
gewesen dass lautet nämlich an haftungs
paradigmen jeder ist für sich selber
verantwortlich
die sollen gefälligst ihre hausarbeiten
machen wir sind nicht der zahlmeister
europas nur wenn eines dieser länder
abschmiert innerhalb der europäischen
union dann weiß man nie so genau wie die
erschütterungsdynamik läuft und welche
über sprungs effekte es gibt das weiß
man erst hinterher wenn es vielleicht zu
spät ist war das puristische sparen im
norden europas geht es für die für das
katholische südeuropa das im ausgeben
immer etwas lockerer und flexibler war
ist das hat sich da eine entwicklung in
gang gesetzt unter die wir heute leiten
innerhalb der eurozone
wer die entwicklung gab es ja vorher
schon dass die ökonomin im norden und im
süden sich sehr sehr unterschiedlich
entwickelt haben saß aber vorher nicht
so gut weil weil die wirtschaft einfach
gut lief und man dachte das passt schon
alles und erst in der krise haben sich
dann große unterschiede heraus gestellt
auch was deutschland und frankreich zum
beispiel angeht die haben immer von
ähnlichen begriffen geredet aber
eigentlich was völlig anderes gemeint
die deutschen wollten er sozusagen sich
dass man sich klar an die regeln halten
die franzosen meinten bei dem gleichen
ort immer eine lösung muss man ein
bisschen flexibel gucken und erst die
finanzkrise hat dann offenbar
offengelegt welche großen unterschieden
eurozone es überhaupt gab und aber auch
schon vorher gab diese unterschiede die
und die gefährdung die sind entstanden
so behaupte ich durch den euro selber
schavan die länder unterschiedlich
kräftig sowieso aber vor dem euro
mussten die länder südeuropas diese
riesigen zinsen zahlen
1995 beim gipfel von madrid als der euro
oder überhaupt beschlossen wurde musste
italien spanien portugal 12 prozent
zahlen wer in deutschland sieben
heiraten ja und dann auf einmal als der
euro beschlossen war fielen die zinsen
auf das deutsche niveau die griechischen
fielen sogar von 25 auf das deutsche
niveau
das war natürlich eine tolle zeit da war
plötzlich geld für alles und jedes dame
hat sich verschuldet um die gehälter
beim start zu vergrößern
die privatleute haben sich verschuldet
umzubauen das gaben bauboom
es gab kredit getriebenen lohnerhöhungen
die länder kamen in einwohnern seien ein
super boom der zur blase wurde die dann
zum lehman zeitpunkt platzte und dann zu
dem zeitpunkt sind eigentlich torsos
einst halbwegs wettbewerbsfähiger länder
übrig geblieben die total überteuert
waren durch diese inflationäre blase die
der euro selber erzeugt hatte weil der
euro den investoren signalisiert ihr
könnt jetzt überall hingehen
alle länder sind sicher ihr kriegt das
geld auf jeden fall wieder jeder hat die
druckerpresse ja im keller und kann im
zweifel mit einer währung zurückzahlen
in die er sich in der sich verschuldet
hat wenn man mal die letzten zehn jahre
von heute ab zurück guckt mit dem
ausbruch der krise bis zum heutigen tag
dann gibt es zwei gruppen die da die
gelackmeierten offensichtlich sind das
sind die jungen leute in südeuropa die
von einer trotz wieder besserer
wirtschaft von einer gravierenden
arbeitslosigkeit betrogen betroffen sind
und ja offensichtlich auch relativ
schlechte zukunftsaussichten haben und
der deutsche sparer vor allen dingen der
mit nullzinsen jetzt sein vermögen nicht
mehr wehren kann
sind das die beiden die da die sozusagen
ist die zeche zahlen oder gibts da noch
mehr
ja es gibt noch viel viel mehr natürlich
aber die südschiene europas ist de facto
tatsächlich bankrott im zins kostet des
euros werden die niemals wieder auf die
beine kommen wir sehen sie das von
griechenland über spanien italien
hunderttausende von jungen menschen das
land verlassen und woanders eine
perspektive zu finden
ja parallel sehen wir auch dass die
länder nicht mehr auf einen grünen zweig
kommt das enorme probleme haben
also es der sparer wird enteignet durch
ein einmaliges historisches notenbank
experiment par excellence wir haben
historisch tiefe zinsen bei null
keiner weiß wie dieses spiel ausgeht
keiner hier in der runde
und ich bin auch der überzeugung dass
der vertrag die zinsen gar nicht mehr
markant erhöhen kann man sonst in die
südländischen sterben sofort de facto
bankrott also die enteignung der sparer
geht weiter sie starten freut es
natürlich vor allem auch die
bundesrepublik die kann sich so günstig
verschulden wie noch nie und freut sich
schon sehr gar nicht tut weil sie
inzwischen die schwarze null als genau
das vor sich her aber auch nur zum teil
wegen der gesunkenen zinsen profitieren
zwar nicht so stark wie die anderen aber
auch als gestiegen inzwischen in der
verfassung also da darf ist es
tatsächlich mit den zinsen nichts mehr
passieren
es ist ein heißes spiel und wir würden
bis hin zu überlegen wie lange dieses
experiment ein experiment noch
funktionieren kann und keiner weiß wie
es ausgeht und deswegen muss man sich
einfach darauf gefasst machen dass wir
eine altersarmut welle erleben in
südeuropa aber natürlich auch in
deutschland wir haben keine
möglichkeiten adäquat fürs alter
vorzusorgen nicht im zuge einer
nullzinsphase lebensversicherung
funktionieren nicht mehr staatsanleihen
sind wohl gefährlich was muss man machen
deswegen steigen ja auch dann die asset
preise für immobilien aber auch für
aktienmarkt
und da entsteht hat eine neue
finanzmarktblase nach der anderen um die
vorherigen abzulösen
und das ist natürlich brandgefährlich
gebe ihnen mal eine zahl hätten die
deutschen in ihrer gesamtheit auf das
netto auslandsvermögen das sie besitzen
netto netto netto über alles inklusive
start und einem aller privaten noch zehn
jahre lang die zinsen des jahres 2007
verdient dann werden sie heute um 700
milliarden euro reicher
warum auch immer die zinsen niedrig sind
ich will jetzt keine schuld aussprechen
das sagen dass die ezb das war oder so
dass ich trotzdem ist deutschland
reicher geworden und trotzdem geht es
deutschland in europa niemals und gut
ich kann mit diesen horror szenarien wie
vor ist da ja nur gut wir sind ein
bisschen profitiert des euros absolut
geht der export brummt ohne ende des
deutschen antwort auch auf fernsehen
denn die frage stellt sich ja was folgt
aus dem was der sinn gesagt hat eine
rückkehr eine rückabwicklung des euro
unvorstellbar jetzt kommt das ist das
was ich sagen will ich sagen dass es ist
eine wenn dann aussage das kann ja jeder
selber nachrechnen und es ist mal
wichtig sich das klar zu machen weil er
immer so gesagt wird diese ganze
rechnerei und die zinspolitik das kostet
uns nichts deutschland ist per saldo der
größte zweitgrößte nettogläubiger der
welt nach japan durch die großen
exportüberschüsse haben wir riesige
auslandsvermögen die uns eigentlich
zinserträge bringen und diese
zinserträge sind nun eben nicht mehr
richtig da das ist dass plötzlich ein
teil des der der ausgleichenden
gerechtigkeit und würde ja die
schieflage noch größer werden zwischen
einer prosperierte exportnation und
anderen ländern die auf dem zahnfleisch
gehen ökonomen ja sie können natürlich
sagen ihr nachbar hat erhalten kredit
aufgenommen von ihnen und hat über seine
verhältnisse gelebt und jetzt
kann er den zins nicht mehr zahlen jetzt
senken die den zins das ja nicht pleite
geht das ist immer noch besser er würde
mein nachbar kann keine gehen wenn
frankreich ktg der das für unseren sagt
man schlechter wir wollen ja auch nicht
hoffen
das problem ist man muss vorher bremsen
man darf diese exzesse wiese
schuldenexzesse gar nicht als passieren
lassen und da finde ich es gut dass er
herr steinbrück hier ist der hat nämlich
später die schuldenbremse als
finanzminister für deutschland mal
durchgesetzt mann der staat darf sich
gar nicht mehr verschulden und das
sollten wir mal in den anderen ländern
auch verlieren aber eine frage herr
steinbrück glauben sie dass der euro
funktioniert wir sind was er nicht
funktioniert ich mache eine wette dass
es den euro auch 29 und 30 jahren geben
wird ich mache länder der das ist mein
zweites ich mache keine wette dass
dieselben mitgliedstaaten sind wir jetzt
aber stellen sie sich vor die d-mark
findet oder hat damals stattgefunden in
einem land das genau dieselben
divergenzen oder gefälle gehabt hat wie
heute europa zwischen mecklenburg
vorpommern und von mir aus zwischen
bayern oder dem stuttgarter raum
das heißt auch die d mark war eine
einheitliche währung in einem
wirtschaftsraum der sich durch
wahnsinnig hohe unterschiede divergenzen
unterschiedliche arbeitslosigkeit
wertschöpfungen ein komplott darstellte
das ist ziemlich vergleichbar mit europa
die frage ist nur welche
ausgleichsmechanismen und welche
spielregeln erlasse ich um das
auszugleichen aber es wird in
deutschland entschuldigen noch nicht
ganz zu ende
in deutschland haben sie dafür bestimmte
mechanismen an den horizontalen und
vertikalen finanzausgleich sie haben
gemeinschaft steuern etc
und sie haben ein gemeinsames regelwerk
und einen gemeinsamen staat der eine
versicherungsgesellschaft auf
gegenseitig gleich wie die deutschen
sich das haben wir in europa noch nicht
ob wir noch nicht das liegt aber auch
daran und dahin kommen wir an den
kernpunkt dass die meisten europäischen
ländern nicht bereit sind weitere
souveräne rechte an eine europäische
institutionen abzugeben
das ist der kernpunkt und daran
scheitert die vervollkommnung der
europäischen delegation dann kommt die
frage dann kommt gleich die frage wie
wahrscheinlich jetzt ein problem
gestellt wird war der euro die
einführung des euro im jahre 2002 an
früh stadt ist es zu früh gekommen
also ich finde wenn man die debatte
immer verengt auf diesen deutschen
sparer finde ich das ist nur die halbe
wahrheit denn natürlich haben wir jetzt
niedrigere zinsen und natürlich hat der
deutsche sparer gelitten hätte er in
aktien angelegt vielleicht weniger
klamauk klammer zu aber nicht desto
trotz hat seinen job behalten wir haben
wir haben durch den euro
sie haben sie gerade alle bestätigt
haben wir eine wirtschaft die wirklich
gut funktioniert wir haben fast keine
arbeitslosigkeit mehr
und das wird glaube ich für die meisten
menschen im bereich wichtiger wichtiger
als das was im spar konnte liegt denn
der job ist zusätzlich zum geld auch
noch im sinn stiften im moment im leben
und das ist glaube ich habe menschen
entscheiden
die kluft zwischen arm und reich wird
immer größer und vor allem das nicht
unterschlagen dass 25 prozent der
arbeitnehmer in prekären
arbeitssituationen arbeiten also wir
profitieren davon dass knapp acht
millionen menschen in diesem jahr an
millionen menschen 8 millionen menschen
die vom land von ihrer hände arbeit
gefragt und nicht erleben können nicht
auf die seite legen können da kommt ein
riesen problem auf uns daran ist jetzt
der euro nicht schuld euro ist schon als
sie doch recht das ist ja doch jetzt
gemildert worden
durch die günstige wettbewerbssituation
von deutschland das ist die kehrseite
der süden wurde zu teuer
durch die inflation deutschland hatte
keine inflation deutschland wurde
relativ immer günstiger und hat dadurch
jetzt eine prächtige wettbewerbslage das
ist genau das was sie beschreiben und
aber man werden als eigentlich auch zu
billig sein ist nicht wenn man zu billig
ist da hat man zwar viel zu tun man
kriegt aber für die exportgüter nicht
mehr viel zurück ich habe also die
austausche relation mit dem ausland sind
schlecht gehen der ganz so billig sein
man kann zu teuer sei nirgendwo gibt es
ein optimum an damit die
arbeitslosigkeit hat er meistens zufolge
das eben fachkräftemangel herrscht und
gehen die löhne auch nach oben das ist
ja möglicherweise auch einen mechanismus
steinbrück welche maßnahmen die man
damals getroffen worden sind waren denn
richtig die funktionieren auch heute und
was muss noch unbedingt getan werden sie
haben ja selbst gesagt die eigenkapital
regierung ist noch nicht optimal
für die für die internationalen
finanzsysteme wo das es naheliegend dass
die eigenkapitalanforderungen betrifft
nach dem motto das nicht mehr
stattfindet auf zwei euro die ich selber
habe kann ich 98 euro aufnehmen und
damit dann auch spekulieren
womit wir bei einigen themen sind die
wir noch gar nicht erörtert haben wo
noch weitere risiken sind manchmal im
derivatehandel also wetten auf
zukünftige preise wie hoch ist die ist
die spekulative blase da drin
ich glaube dass es drei oder vier dinge
gibt die eine enorme rolle spielen das
sind erstens die nach wie vor faulen
kredite auf vielen banken die
ländergruppe ich schätze morgen mit 4
700 bis 720 milliarden euro
20 teile die einschätzung von herrn sinn
dass der nettovermögens exporte in
deutschland betrieben hat in der tat ein
problem ist die deutsche bundesbank hat
finanziell gesehen forderungen an die
anderen zentralbanken in europa
wahrscheinlich in einer größenordnung
die inzwischen fast 800 milliarden 113
war schon mal dass das wird nicht dann
das wird erst dann ein problem wenn ein
land wirklich in die pleite gehen sollte
oder den offenbarungseid leisten sollte
aber dahinter steht und das teile ich
eine enorme potential dieser länder dass
deutschland sich eine etwas laxeren
handhabung der budgetpolitik doch
ergeben solle nach dem motto sonst bist
du etwas was ich 30 prozent an den
entsprechenden verlusten beteiligt was
in die milliarden gehen würde
ich glaube dass die banken union
vervollkommnet werden sollte mit der
bankenaufsicht sind wir weit
vorangekommen für die 120 ungefähr
größten grenzüberschreitenden banken bei
dem abwicklungs mechanismus von
illiquiden oder insolvent gehenden
banken sind wir noch nicht so weit wie
wir sollten und die dritte säule wäre
eine gemeinsame europäische
einlagensicherung die wird aber erst
kommen wenn die bankenbilanzen wirklich
bereinigt worden sind von diesen faulen
krediten in der größenordnung die ich
genannt habe
ich habe mir da nicht angst dass das
wieder zur zockerei führt solch eine
gemeinsame einlagensicherung usa wird
hier die regulierung wieder
zurückgefahren die tiere grün gerade in
dem in dem bereich der spekulativen
märkte also in eine thema usa die usa
haben in den 80er jahren die sparkassen
krise gehabt da sind 1000 über 1000
sparkassen untergegangen
und das hat den start über 100
milliarden dollar gekostet
nach einem untersuchungsbericht des
amerikanischen kongresses war der grund
dafür die zockerei dieser sparkassen die
haben eine gefährliche
fristentransformation gemacht und die
ursache war tatsächlich die
einlagensicherung
es gab eine gemeinsame eigen
einlagensicherung die einlagensicherung
hat die zombie banken die es eben gab in
die lage versetzt gelder kundengelder zu
attackieren und mit diesem kundengeldern
haben sie dann rum gezockt das ist das
wirkliche problem wenn wir eine
europäische einlagensicherung machen
selbst über die altlasten beseitigen
dann haben die banken zyperns die ja
mächtig rum gezockt hatten und auch
schon pleite gegangen waren
die gelegenheit einlagen aus ganz europa
an zu sammeln und dann in der welt herum
zu zocken
das wollen wir doch nicht wiederholen
also wurde vom einlagensicherung kann
man ja auch machen auf nationaler ebene
hat er habe ja auch und das könnten die
anderen jetzt ja mal auch machen wir
haben ja noch keine gesamtdeutsche
einlagensicherung sondern verschiedene
private einlagensicherungssysteme das
könnte man den anderen europäern doch
erst einmal empfehlen bevor sie jetzt
rufen nach einer gemeinsam absicherung
der st das wird auch der erste schritt
sein also wir haben was vielleicht für
die zuschauer nicht ganz klar ist wir
haben wegen der privaten banken wegen
der genossenschaftsbank und wegen der
öffentlich rechtlichen banken drei
verschiedenen einlagensicherungssysteme
in deutschland in der tat ob man die
vereinheitlichen kann weiß ich nicht
genau
vor dem hintergrund der
unterschiedlichen rechtsformen der erste
schritt wäre in der tat vergleichbare
einlagensicherungssysteme auch in den
anderen ländern dabei zu vernehmen
übrigen ist immer die frage wie man
diese zockerei bekämpft durch
entsprechende mechanismen und dann
schauen wir wieder zu ihren
eigenkapitalregeln er die frage ist ja
werden sie bekämpft ich formuliere ich
frage mal etwas anders müssen wir wieder
befürchten diese sogenannten toxischen
papiere zu kriegen mit denen die ja eine
der gründe waren für das elend der zeit
von 2008
es gibt ja allen die die toxischen
papiere also die papiere wo in einem
riesigen sack diverse einzelne kredite
drin sind und dann wird auf den sack
triple l geschrieben in wirklichkeit ist
häufig triple z drin
das ist der ausgangspunkt übrigens
dieser finanzkrise wäre
da war zu viel drin aber es gibt
diejenigen die es kreieren und es gibt
die genies kaufen das sind zwei
unterschiedliche paar schuhe
also von mir aus können machen wir ja
gerne diese produkte kreieren
die frage ist wer kauft so etwas diese
krankheit ist ein aktueller höher wie
vor der krise die haltungs nur anders
schließen sie die augen und die banken
freuen sich ein lukrativer gewinne
wieder das heißt wir in europa auch
machen mit den sogenannten sbs ja dass
die papiere die die jetzt bei der
zentralbank sind wenn die zurückverkauft
werden nicht so zurückverkauft werden
sondern gebündelt als abs-papiere nicht
das sind massenvernichtungswaffen so
hatte seinerzeit gesagt und das ist
jetzt als lösung des europäischen
problems angesehen sonst kommen wir aus
dieser trage ich ja gar nicht anders
sehe das was ich jetzt irre leiten dann
geht es um die gier warum die überhaupt
gekauft werden sinnvolle auf sicht
sinnvolle kontrolle sinnvolle
regulierung da ist in die hausaufgaben
wir noch nicht alle gemacht ist das
eigentlich bei der derzeitigen
politischen lage den politischen
kräfteverhältnissen in europa in den usa
ist es überhaupt realistisch zu glauben
dass man ein solch eine solche anzeichen
eines solchen crash eine solche krise
wenn sie wiederkommen sollte tatsächlich
in den griff bekommt also wenn man sich
anschaut welche politiker jetzt an der
macht sind oder immer stärker werden
welche kräfte mache ich mir da exakt
bisschen sorgen
vor zehn jahren waren überall relativ
besonnen regierungen an der macht heute
sieht das bekanntermaßen deutlich anders
aus und wenn noch mal so eine globale
krise ausbrechen würde wahrscheinlich
sieht die anders aus und kommt nicht aus
diesen dubiosen papieren sondern aus
einer irgendeiner anderen ecke sonst
würde man sehr viel leichter vorher
abfedern können aber dann habe ich schon
sorgen wie man dann global
zusammenarbeiten soll sowie das klima
jetzt ist zwischen den nationen dadurch
auf der auf der tatsächlichen aufsichts
ebene glaube ich sind wir einen
deutlichen schritt weiter und ich glaube
auch dass die behörden arbeiten würden
das ist ja sozusagen die spitze der
hitzkopf und darunter haben
der immer noch ein apparate funktioniert
also deswegen ist sozusagen nicht hopfen
malz verloren aber das erstarken der
populisten ist direkte antwort dieser
krise zwar das hat auch den nährboden
für populistische kräfte des linken und
rechten lagers weil nicht weil die
menschen sich einfach in separaten haben
gefühl dass wir haben historischen
vertrauensverlust damals erstens mit der
finanzwelt weil die menschen gedacht
haben
der ehrbare kaufmann ist nicht derjenige
der uns abgezockt wir haften jetzt zu
denen dann hat die politik in sicht des
bürgers gemeinsame sache gemacht hand in
hand mit der finanzwelt hatte gerettet
die bürger müssten dafür zahlen und
deshalb haben wir bis heute und deswegen
haben politische kräfte trump drexhage
fünf sterne bewegung afd
in unglaublichen aufschwung ist auch
weiter gehen leider das war historisch
wohl immer schon so das ifw und das
institut für weltwirtschaft haben sich
mal den letzten 200 jahren war nach
finanzkrisen angeschaut das war immer so
dass die populisten danach sehr
profitiert haben und fast immer waren es
die rechtspopulisten es ist schon
bedenklich allerdings war es meistens so
dass nach zehn jahren sich der effekt
wieder normalisiert hat diesmal nicht
brauchen linke in italien es ist nur
eine finanzkrise es ist die wettbewerbs
krise die der euro in der zeit vor der
finanzkrise auslöste indem er die länder
südeuropas hoffnungslos überteuerten die
bräuchten jetzt eine abwertung ihrer
währung können sie nicht sehr ich den
euro weil sie den euro haben dann können
sie ihre preise senken senken sie mal
die preise
das ist eine chemotherapie der kann eine
gesellschaft zerbrechen
die alternative ist dass deutschland
nach inflationiert werden
wir blieben mit den preisen am boden die
anderen jetzt sollen wir folgen das will
die ezb aber ist das gericht gegen wurde
den sparern lässt sich deutschland
überhaupt nach inflationieren und wenn
wir das alles nicht wollen dann bleibt
also nur das was er machen will eine
transfer union das heißt wir machen
unser portemonnaie auch und geschrieben
jedes jahr was rüber zu den ländern die
nicht wettbewerbsfähige bundes
länderfinanzausgleich auf prosieben das
wirklich auch nicht welche hier zu viel
geld und er stand der welche politischen
gefahren lauern in den gesellschaften
der jetzt gerade von populismus
gesprochen dass da ja auch unglaublich
viel vertrauen zerstört worden ist
porzellan zerschlagen worden ist wie
groß ist der schaden gerade was
das vertrauen in der gesellschaft in die
politik angeht also ich teile die these
von den friedrich und ja auch in
anwendungen annahmen sind es gibt eine
verbindung von der finanzkrise zu dem
enormen vertrauensverlust gegenüber den
etablierten politischen parteien und
auch regierungen nicht ganz so
monokausal wie sie ist dargelegt haben
aber die erste welle ist ja eine anti
europäische anti eu anti euro welle
gewesen es war übrigens der
gründungsakte afd in deutschland dann
ging die afg aber ziemlich wieder nicht
ganz in die bedeutungslosigkeit sagte
ziemlich ab nur dann kam der zweite
auslöser mit blick auf den vorwurf eines
kontrollverlustes der demokratische
politische institutionen das war die
flüchtlingswelle und auf der welle surft
sie bis heute an schließlich natürlich
ihrer vorstellung von protektionismus
antieuropäischen tendenzen und der euro
muss weg und dergleichen insofern es
gibt dort eine verbindung nicht ganz so
direkt wie einige das darstellen aber in
der tat glaube ich dass die finanzkrise
die bankenkrise eine langzeitwirkung
gehabt er mit einer tiefen erschütterung
des vertrauens von vielen menschen in
die kontroll- und handlungsfähigkeit der
politischen institution nicht
notwendigerweise eine anti europäische
bewegung das ist zu billig mit verlaub
sondern das ist auch der versuch
jedenfalls bei vielen ökonomen den euro
funktionsfähig zu machen ist ja kaputt
der funktioniert der überhaupt nicht und
man muss da ein anderes system
hinstellen und meine vorstellung ist und
macht eine atmende währungsunion wie
schäuble das wollte dass also die länder
die nicht zurechtkommen euro dann auch
mal temporär austreten abwerten wird
gewerbs fähig werden und schwer
irgendetwas muss passieren
es gibt so viele dinge die man machen
muss und die salden die tage zu halten
die sie angesprochen haben mit fast 1000
milliarden aber es kann doch auch nicht
so zu lassen
das gehört irgendwie gedeckelt und
getilgt ja dass die leute wieder an die
kapitalmärkte geben gehen statt sich das
geld zu drucken das sie brauchen um zu
leben um ihre schulden im ausland zurück
zu zahlen um hier in berlin
immobilien zu kaufen das sind auch alles
missstände sondergleichen das kann man
so ein
also man mag sich kaum vorstellen dass
der ständige außen einzigen die eurozone
bei den politischen
spielräumen die politik hat und die ja
auch vor allem namen politischen und
administrativen aufwand erfordert ja
2015 finanzminister hatte schäuble auf
seine seite gebracht und wäre
griechenland 2015 ausgetreten hense
abgewertet dann werden sie meines
erachtens heute aus dem schneider wir
haben ja wir haben ja jetzt gesagt was
sie alles gelernt haben aus christ-
finanzkrise 2008 wenn steinbrück morgen
etwas ähnliches passieren würde
wie auch immer crash sind hier
wenn er morgen käme sind wir besser
gerüstet da sind wir überhaupt gerüstet
müssen wir uns da nicht mehr so viel
sorgen machen oder ist das reine
spekulation also besser gerüstet sind
wir der bankensektor ist robuster als
2007/2008 die internationale
zusammenarbeit es besser und intensiver
es gibt einschlägige institutionen dafür
dass schicke ich alles voraus so dass
wir nicht nur uns hier mit asche
überhäufen und sagen es ist alles ganz
schrecklich
das ändert nichts daran dass es nach wie
vor erhebliche risiken gibt ich habe die
schattenbanken noch gar nicht erwähnt
ich habe die private mit ihrer möglichen
spekulative blase erwähnt wir haben
geredet über die faulen kredite
wir haben darüber geredet in der tat
dass die geldpolitik über die
nullzinspolitik der bundesbank letztlich
als instrument sich dagegen zu operieren
sich erschöpft hat wenn man ein ziel hat
dann ist das letztlich ist dieses
geldpolitische instrumentarium zum
erliegen gekommen dass bleiben wir noch
viele ein finanzpolitisches
instrumentarium das sind alles
belastende faktoren aber ich glaube dass
die die sensibilität und die
bereitschaft ein gemeinsames
krisenmanagement zu entwickeln
mindestens besser entwickelt ist als wir
das 2000 an beginnt ja jedes gewitter
erst mal mit wetterleuchten wenn wir auf
länder schauen die scheinbar so ein
bisschen der peripherie sind ökonomische
und finanzpolitisch wie die türkei und
argentinien in der türkei ein
unglaublicher sturz der währung eine
wahnsinns inflation in argentinien in
diesem jahr übrigens nicht zum ersten
mal sind auch vorboten die sich dann so
von der peripherie ins zentrum ziehen
oder ist das eine überinterpretation
dieser situation wenn wir gucken wie
geht es jetzt auf den internationalen
finanzmärkten weiter ich glaube das ist
jetzt keine direkten vorboten sind zumal
gerade die beiden länder
ökonomisch mit der eu nicht so sehr
verbandelt sind wie das jetzt bei den
bei der damaligen finanzkrise der fall
war
was ich mir jedoch wünschen würde ist
dass wir haben es so viel darüber
gesprochen was die zahlen und was wir
zahlen
ich glaube uns ist allen klar dass die
krise uns gezeigt hat dass globale
probleme globale lösungen erfordern
deswegen würde ich mir wünschen dass
alle klugen köpfe dieses landes daran
arbeiten wie wir dieses wir dieses
europa voranbringen gemeinsam denn nur
da liegt die zukunft wir haben keine
chance als deutschland alleine gegen
china oder die usa vorsorglich muss das
zentrum der aufmerksamkeit wird es
gestärkt in denen wir dieses regime das
zu massenarbeitslosigkeit in südeuropa
geführt hat fortführen oder indem wir
die wettbewerbliche cent wunsch machen
dass arbeitsplätze im süden entstehen
und das heißt dass man doch mal ran muss
an dieses system und das grundlegend
nach nach so vielen jahren jetzt mal
reformieren musste
und da kann man nicht sind wir beim euro
nicht eigentlich die europäer sind sich
eigentlich aus überall unangenehm
das ist ein problem alles unter einen
hut zu bringen und wie gesagt im zins
kostet der ezb werden die südlichen
länder europas als auch den grünen zweig
kommen und ich denke für die nächste
krise können wir uns auf jeden fall
anschnallen weil die verschuldung hat
sich fast verdreifacht seit 2007 die
probleme sind immer noch da es wurde nur
sozusagen herumgedoktert an den
symptomen aber nicht an den wirklichen
ursachen und in neue krise sind die
frage ob die kommt sondern wann eine
neue chance ist unterwegs sage ich ihnen
und zwar kommt sie von amerika wie 1981
als regan durch seine defizitpolitik die
zinsen hoch getrieben hat und dem dollar
aufgewertet hat damals purzelten alle
parteien lateinischen länder in amerika
mexiko erst brasilien und welche
möglichkeiten wir sind so eine theorie
aber durchaus bei indonesien und
argentinien haben heute ähnliche
probleme die währungen werten ab die
banken sind in dollar verschuldet sie
müssen das in heimischer währung
bilanzieren die schulden gehen in den
himmel eigenkapital weg banken klein
können diese noch nicht beendet und 28
sekunden ohne einen kleinen
hoffnungsschimmer ja das ist ja alles
etwas zu deterministisch dann kann ich
an meinem bett bleiben und
schon vor der tür und der gleich nein
das ist nicht zwingend sondern es muss
gelingen insbesonder deutschland und
frankreich aus diesem wahnsinnigen
paradigma streit auf der einen seite das
haftungsrisiko deutschlands auf der
anderen seite das vergemeinschaftung
prinzip der franzosen endlich zu
überwinden und es gehört dazu dass wir
den menschen die uns zuhören genau sagen
dass europa nicht das problem ist
sondern die lösung recht die meisten
probleme die wir haben lassen sich nicht
mehr in der nationalen reichweite von
politik lösen
ich bedanke mich dass ich da dabei
angeblich alle schauer morgen die
phoenix runde der fall maßen
verfassungsschutz unter druck bleiben
sie bei uns im selben kreis